Welcome to
Google Developers Hackademy.
This is the third part
of the Google Apps Script course
created by Antonio Guzman,
from GDG Androititlan Mexico.
If this is your first contact
with the course,
I recommend you watch it
in order and do the exercises.
Welcome to the third lesson
of the Google Apps Script
introduction course,
I'm Antonio Guzman.
In this lesson we will
integrate a script
to a spreadsheet and execute it
upon a certain event:
the opening of the spreadsheet.
Today's themes are
container-bound scripts,
The Tools menu options,
which are Script Gallery,
Script Manager
and Script Editor.
Finally, the ranges
of a spreadsheet
and the notation we use.
When we talk about
container-bound scripts,
we talk about the type
of scripts accessible
from Google Forms,
Google Document
and Google Spreadsheet.
These scripts allow us
to extend the functionality
of those applications.
A comparison would be macros,
and in this lesson
we will build a script
from a spreadsheet.
LET'S GET TO WORK
Let's go to Drive.
We already have a spreadsheet
with some data.
We decided to put
the names of the months
and a numeric value,
which is right
its corresponding month number.
Now we will notate
this option, Tools.
If you see, Tools has 3 options
for scripts.
The first one is Script Gallery,
Script Manager
and we also have Script Editor.
In Script Gallery we'll find
a whole script collection
already developed by others,
we don't need
to reinvent the wheel,
there's already plenty of things
we can take,
and besides, they're classified
by category.
We just need to find
what we're interested in
and we can use it.
The other option I mentioned
is Script Manager.
From Script Manager
we'll be able to list
all the scripts
we have associated
to our spreadsheet
or to create a new one.
This time we don't have any.
Let's move on.
Script Editor will be the option
that will let us build,
in this case, the script that
will perform the functionality
that we have planned.
You know,
every time we enter,
we will see
the welcoming screen.
The same, a blank project.
We want everything from scratch.
We select it
and we move on.
We are going to name our script.
"gas."
Let's say, that nomenclature.
"gas03."
We save it and done.
Let's write our function
and extract the data
from our spreadsheet.
We declare our variable
and we use the
"SpreadsheetApp" class.
In SpreadsheetApp
we find a method
that in this case is
"getActive".
This time we won't
open it by ID,
we will use
"getActiveSpreadsheet."
That means it's going to take
the spreadsheet
that, in the context of
our script, is executing it,
the active one.
Now, we declare
our sheet variable,
where we will associate
that first sheet in our spread.
That's where we will
paint our chart.
So "spread.getSheet"
and now we have our sheet.
Which in this case is just one,
so we reference
the first element
and there we go.
Now we need to create the chart.
Let's create a variable
called "chart"
and, on our sheet,
we're going to use the method
that allows us to create it.
We're going to use "newChart."
"newChart" has several options.
We'll go through them.
The first will be
the type of chart we want.
Which one? We're going to pick
the BAR type.
So "ChartType..."
But BARS is not the only type,
there's AREA,
we also have...
I don't know, PIE, a classic,
but we'll stay
with the BAR type.
Now, we're going to identify
the information
we want to paint.
So we need to indicate
the information range.
To do that, we're going to use
the "a1 Notation."
That's the one we will use
in most of the cases.
This a1 notation is the one,
you know this,
it's a text chain which is
"first column,"
left upper corner
of our data arrangement,
and we write right lower corner,
if we see it as a rectangle.
In this case it is A1,
which is the first one,
and B12, the last one.
We will also indicate
where we want it.
If you see, here we have
four location options
so we will give "5"
to the initial values
and we leave 0
for offsetX and offsetY.
Now our chart is configured.
Then, after that,
what we have to do
is building our chart.
There's a method for that,
"build," so we use it,
we finish our sentence,
you know with a ";"
This way we now have a chart.
But, what's left?
Painting and inserting it.
Where? In our sheet.
So we reference it:
"sheetChart..."
and, what are we going to do?
Insert, insert a chart.
So we finish our sentence
with a semicolon,
and then we save our script.
Now the function is saved,
everything's set,
but now what do we have to do?
We're talking about
a contained script
in the context of a spreadsheet,
So we want it to be executed
in that context.
Let's create an extra function.
"function onOpen."
This function will be
automatically executed
every time the event
"onOpen" takes place,
that means every time someone
opens our spreadsheet,
"myFunction" is going
to be called, so let's do it.
onOpen we call myFunction...
and, this way,
we'd already have
our script ready
so it can be used.
Now... we run it.
It tells us
it's starting to run.
Again, it'll request
authorization, there it is,
so we grant it...
It lets us know what kind
of data it'll have access to,
which is the spreadsheets,
and that's it,
our script has run.
Let's go back
to the spreadsheet.
There's the chart,
but we want...
Let's delete it.
Because what we want
is that chart to be painted
every time
the spreadsheet is open,
and not only when the script
is run manually,
but automatically
and in context. Let's close it.
We close it... You see?
The script was closed too.
Because it's a contained script,
a script you can't see
from Google Drive.
You see? It's not there.
Let's reopen our spreadsheet.
It's loading...
It's being processed...
the order is sent
that "onOpen"
"myFunction" is executed.
What does myFunction do?
It paints the chart
with the data on the left
and there we have our chart.
Each one of the months
with the values we marked.
Now we go back to Tools.
Remember that Script Manager
had the function list?
There it is, the function
and script list,
"myFunction" and "onOpen."
If we want, we can edit it
from there.
We're waiting for it to open,
we will verify
that it takes us directly
to that function we had.
It's loading and, done,
there is our script.
Now we accessed it
through the Script Manager.
Let's close
the Script Manager...
we check everything's fine...
it closes...
we close our spreadsheet
and, automatically,
our script closes too,
because it's a contained script.
LET'S DO AN EXERCISE
In order to reaffirm
this lesson themes,
we will do an exercise.
Let's use a container-bound
type script
to add a 16% tax
to a series of ten products.
Then, we will build a chart,
but it won't be colored
on the first sheet,
we color it on a second one
and with the data comprising
from the 3rd
to the 7th products.
In the first sheet
we leave the values
for product price, product tax
and the result of price-tax.
Finally, I recommend
you go to Script Gallery
and explore it.
RECAPITULATION
Let's remember
that in this lesson
we saw the definition for
container-bound script,
the options in the Tools menu:
Script Gallery, Script Manager
and Script Editor.
We also saw the ranges
and their notation.
In the next lesson
we're going to work
with another type of scripts,
container extension scripts,
and we'll integrate
more services:
Gmail, Forms,
Drive, Documents y Spreadsheet.
That will be all for now.
Keep on programming.